you
good morning Hank it's Monday November
26th as you can tell puffs levels are a
little bit high today I have to turn in
the final revision of Paper Towns
tomorrow evening and I'm a little
stressed Hank in other news when mom and
dad were here for Thanksgiving they
brought three boxes full of my childhood
stuff Hank perhaps most exciting is this
Eagles Nest Camp t-shirt from 1987 Hank
it was at Eagle's Nest camp in 1987 that
I dated and got dumped by my very first
girlfriend who kissed me I mean we were
10 so it was just like but still I am
referring of course to Tiffany with no
last name who also holds the distinction
of being the only one of my
ex-girlfriends whose last name I don't
know and who therefore I cannot look up
on Facebook god Hank I can't tell you
how much I would love to know Tiffany
with no last names last name but
unfortunately I have very few clues to
go on because I was 10 when Tiffany with
no last name and I dated I don't
remember a lot of the details of our
relationship for instance I don't
remember where she was from and I don't
remember anything about what she looked
like in fact Hank in the search for
Tiffany with no last name I can only
provide two sure clues first we know
that when she was 10 she had excellent
penmanship and second we know that she
likes horses
Tiffany's horse says everybody's special
now Hank I don't know how many 30 year
old women there are in America named
Tiffany who liked horses when they were
10 but I swear to God if any
nerdfighters successfully track her down
there will be a very handsome reward
Hank last week our secret brother Alex
posted a video in which he asked if I
had any advice for young aspiring
writers Hank I was thinking about how to
address that question when Mom and Dad
showed up with all my childhood stuff
and I found two new books that I wrote
in elementary school the first is called
my great mini book it's wonderful
amazing I was a humble child I'd like to
read this book to you my friend the Fox
is a very ugly animal
I don't like foxes and then you can see
there the little boy is saying what is
it my friend the rabbit is my favorite
animal I like its fur the tree groaned
don't pick my apples quit okay what's
inside the box I think it's a turtle why
is he alone they don't want to play with
him the end now Hank that book lacks
what I like to call narrative
consistency you know it starts out with
me hating a fox and it ends up with me
being lonely because no one likes me
no one like me because I hate foxes so I
guess the first thing I would say is
that you need to write a story that
unlike my story has a beginning in a
middle and an end also the beginning
shouldn't involve hating foxes and the
end shouldn't involve no one liking you
I think the other book I want to share
with you is a book of short stories I
wrote called
John's stories what can I say like
rainbows Hank this book contains two
stories I'd like to read them both to
you in their entirety the first one is
called my ELF one day when I was
buttoning my shirt a small elf popped
out of my button I went to tell my
mother she did not believe in elves but
there was I said it popped out of my
button but my mom said no the second
story is untitled if I could if I could
be a noisy bunny well I guess I just hop
and skip along the thing about me as an
elementary school writer is that I
hadn't read a lot of books yet I really
think that reading is just as important
as writing when you're trying to be a
writer because it's the only
apprenticeship we have it's the only way
of learning how to write a story the
second thing I would say is that when
you're writing a story and you hope that
one day it will get published you should
write it for other people instead of
just for yourself like in that elf story
I just read the most interesting thing
about that story by far is the elf who
gets almost no time on the page because
I'm too busy making a big to-do about
how mom never believes me when I tell
outrageous lies
now obviously Hank when I was an
eight-year-old pathological liar it
really bothered me personally that mom
didn't believe my lies but Hank from the
perspective of a reader of that story I
mean I'm interested in the interactions
between the mom and the kid that's cool
and everything but give me more elf so
those are my two pieces of advice read a
lot and more elf I'll see you tomorrow
thanks to everyone who helped me get my
euros over the weekend I think I'll give
you guys a raise